you guys both look gorgeous thank you I
don't I underdress and I apologize I was
feeling like we're meeting Drew it's
like a 90s Chic Vibe you know and now
I'm like I should have been like news
you know what's so funny I'm only
dressed this way because I'm at work and
if I was in my normal clothes you would
feel like you're ready to hit the red
carpet
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to
Drew's News podcast where we're giving
you all the quirky fun and inspiring and
yes informative stories that exist in
the world because well we all need it
right now and today we're covering
everything from Love and relationships
and this week I have not one but two
fabulous co-pilots from the podcast
Girls Gotta Eat Rayna Greenberg and
Ashley hesseltine hi yeah you guys thank
you so much for coming here today thank
you for having us I just I'm amazed that
you guys are getting like 2.5 million
like downloads uh you know what does
that feel like knowing that I was
interested Ashley and asking you and I
was like let's save it for the podcast
because I'm genuinely curious you were
in a relationship that like you wanted
to make it work it wasn't like going the
way that you were hoping it was and that
opened you up and matriculated to like
an idea for this podcast or wanting to
do this yeah let's not give him too much
credit no I'm just kidding but I just
yeah screw him I had a light bulb went
off in you
I was in a relationship that there was a
lot happening there was falling in love
there was a real connection there was
seen a future but there was also a lot
of volatility and toxicity and trying to
want him something to work so badly that
just wouldn't and I dabbled in therapy
for a little bit and I was just taking
in so much information I was talking to
friends about their relationships and I
just became so
intrigued with relationships in general
will make what makes them work what
makes them not work how can you be so in
love and this can't work out and that
made me want to just talk about it more
and I knew that I wanted to be that a
podcast would kind of be the next
natural thing for me personally and
everything that I'd done in my career
and they were really gaining a lot of
traction so that's kind of what I felt
like the next step would be obviously
with the comedic twist and then I was
like I just want to talk about dating
and relationships you know like I don't
want to go through another breakup again
and not tell millions of people about it
you know so and Reina then you came in
like what was the impetus for you to
want to jump in and talk about
relationships with the company of
millions of people and I don't say that
judgmentally because I've been an open
book my whole life yeah you know I have
a business partner that you know allows
me to do that of course and an
incredible audience but for me I went
through this really pivotal moment in my
life where my fiance came home the night
before our engagement party and he said
I'm not in love with you and I don't
want to marry you and my whole life just
exploded and I was so humiliated and I
was just like where do I even go for
this this information like who can I
bond with I must be the only person that
anybody's ever broken an engagement with
in the entire world and I didn't even
know where to go for community and
fast forward you know I mean actually we
start the show and we get to talk about
all these things and you get to
normalize these experience for for so
many people for you know Ashley talks a
lot about not wanting to be a mother or
I talk about my fiance leaving me and
things like that and people can like
look at our show and go like I recognize
my experience and I'm normal and it's
gonna be okay and I'm gonna survive and
the things that I want are totally
normal if I want this thing in the
bedroom or in the boardroom or whatever
you want and it's it comes really
natural to both of us we're very open
and we have families that allow us to do
that too like our parents are just so
excited to like see us do what we do
that's so nice yeah because I don't
think that this does work I don't think
being an open book or a curious person
or wanting to explore in a community
style setting I don't even want to call
it in public because I really think
communities like I've just a
well-intended word public feels like
it's you know you're an exhibitionist
and that's for me what it's ever been
I'm just like you know I I have a
problem building walls up with other
people those I save for uh sexual and uh
romantic relationships
um that's where like the walls sort of
go up now in my adulthood but I think
that it's nice to know you're not alone
it's nice to to speak about these things
it's nice to discuss and figure out and
work on things and make progress
and grow also grow up the more the years
go by the sort of more I feel calmer I
know things more I've figured out things
more I'm liking life more I was such a
wobbly calf for so much of my life or at
least it felt that way so I like I like
figuring it all out what else are we
here to do yeah I feel like I've always
he's wanted to talk more about this
stuff so that's what made has made the
show popular who does it you know I
don't like to have small talk with
people I'm just like when's this time
you got laid let's talk about it or you
know tell us about your terrible breakup
like I think yeah it's really how we
like to bond it's like sleepover talk
you know morning after talk it's like
kind of what we fostered in the podcast
they feel like they're just hanging out
with their friends which is kind of
always been the goal yeah and people
listen every week because they want to
catch up on our lives like I can't tell
you how many people find the show and go
back to episode one because they're like
I gotta see how they got there and I
gotta hear about the relationships and
the breakups and it's like musty TV they
want to go back and hear about our whole
lives and as much as our audience has
given to us and says like thank you for
helping me fix a broken relationship or
leave a toxic one or fix a friendship
and they've given us so much too and it
means so much like when somebody hears
us talk about something and they message
and say like thank you so much for
talking about that I thought I was the
only person or you put words to
something I've never are able to
vocalize and yeah it's encouraging it's
exciting
um and by the way can I ask the origin
stories of girls gotta eat and like for
anyone who may not know how you guys
came upon that title it's so catchy it's
so crisp
got me bite to it it is
um yeah I came up with it one day
walking to the L train I mean I just was
like texting with Reina we'd already
decided to do this podcast I was
throwing names out there and I I love
the phrase people sometimes reference a
Friends episode when Phoebe says A
girl's gotta eat I mean I grew up I
didn't grow up but I spent a lot of time
in the South where I feel like the
connotation is like you know girls gotta
go on a bad date to get a free meal I
think there's a world in which a girl's
gotta get her money get her bag or just
get laid or whatever it's open to
interpretation and now I feel like I'm
hearing it more and like when they
someone says like they ate it's like
they did really well they performed
really well they crushed that whatever
so I just it's even I feel like picking
up more attraction and so it just
applies to every area of life it looks
cute on March
[Applause]
I love that yeah well um I'm gonna get
and we love to eat I just need to make
it clear I was a food blogger Ashley and
I love you
I mean literally you could lure me like
the dumbest fish in the sea with like
any bait that's edible um all right well
we'll be right back to serve you more
news including dating terms that you
need to know to the green flags and
relationships that you must pay
attention to
all right well let's get into Story
number one a married woman wrote Into
The Washington Post advice column asking
for guidance on how to comfort her
single friends when they're feeling down
and it sparked a little debate the
article is entitled can a married person
Comfort unhappy single friends and that
is the question here for us right now
guys thoughts yes tell them how your
marriage is like tell them what's going
on in the marriage and everything that's
going wrong that's how you comfort
single people I love to hear about the
terrible going on in my friend's
marriages I'm gonna I'm kind of kidding
but not really like I know I love this
go keep going I think there's a world in
which you think everything's perfect you
think that your friends have these
perfect marriages these perfect families
and kids and marriage and family and
kids are wonderful but I think it's
sometimes helpful to show the cracks if
your friend is complaining you're like
it's not all it's cracked up to be and I
think that's part of it and I'm half
joking but I think that I don't know
right what are your feelings I read this
article and I read the feedback and I
thought it was really interesting and I
think a lot of time listen it's well
intentioned you want to help your
friends but I think a lot of times for
people that are married for a long time
the feedback to their friends can be
like well me and Josh just worked out
because blah blah it's like I'm not
asking you for your very insular
situation and feedback on why your life
is better than mine and why it worked
out for you and it can't work out for me
and
um the feedback in this article was
really great actually because she said
instead of telling somebody like why
your life worked out so well and why
your marriage is so good mine
information about their lives and say
well let's talk about your past and some
patterns and just ask them more
questions about their own life instead
of regurgitating why yours is so great
and I thought that was like really
interesting feedback I also think you
know sometimes
that's not the friend you need to go to
if you just want a vet about being
single I think sometimes it's this could
be on the other person you know like the
friend the married friend felt like they
don't they're not hearing anything I
have to say I'm not sure how to act you
know I want to be like I support you and
I hear you but if they just wanna moan
and groan about being single which is
fine everybody needs to vent maybe find
another single friend to go down the
rabbit hole with I mean God I love this
so much I agree there are some
relationships I look at and I'm like I'm
so relieved I'm single because yeah all
the time relationships are so full of
tension it's like I I'm with couples
sometimes and it's like they're every
move like has this weird like gaspy
nature to it like but I do like the
person moves a cup and the other person
kind of like flinches and reacts to it
and I think that eggshell life I would
just not make it Ashley and I look at
other relationships sometimes and I like
all side history like are you so glad
this is
are you glad this is just like I'm
unbothered I'm just ordering my takeout
hanging out watching Netflix at night
unbothered I'm not I'm not having sex
with anybody that you know but at the
same time I just I don't have to deal
with the bad stuff and that's great I
couldn't agree more and then you know
there are couples I hear about and I
usually hear about them right when I
need it the most like somebody who met
and within four days like got married
but they've been married for 23 years
and they have three beautiful children
and they're figuring it out and do I
know the ins and outs of their
relationship no but I am a hopeless
romantic but I'm also a very pragmatic
person who does not want or need to be
in a relationship or having sex for the
sake of any of it but I'm gonna be 48
years old and I have two kids it's just
naturally where I am I wouldn't have
felt this way 10 20 years ago
um so I I want to get to the place in my
life where I just don't idealize other
people and I'm not fully myself about
what other people have I want to figure
out what's right for me and that has
taken a lot of time of being single and
getting to know myself because I didn't
know myself well enough I was somewhat
of an imprinter as most of us are when
we get into a relationship where we
become half of that other person and I
wanted to become fully whole on my own
I think it's easy to look at other
people's lives and be like I want that
thing and some people are just lucky
both of our brothers have great
marriages Ashley's parents have a great
marriage and that's an interesting
question do we think some people get
lucky I don't think there's anything
easy about a long-term relationship I
don't think you're just like lucky and
it just happens but yeah you know I
think my brother and his wife really
work on it I think they're lucky to have
met at 22 and grown up together and
grown in the same direction and have
like a great life I'm sure that it's
hard but you know I also think like I
look at your life and mine and Ashley's
and I think like I don't know I'm so
proud of my life I think some people
look at us and think I want that yeah I
would forego all this other [ __ ] to
have that I mean yes
dream I feel like I'm in a dream I'm
like this is amazing right now
it's so true we talk about the
romanticization of couples I want to
romanticize the individual and the life
yes yeah we were we're on stage of the
Chicago theater and Ashley and I were
like this is the best night of our Lives
I defy like I I've I love dating okay I
date once or twice a year that's about
as much as I can handle
um and there's even the worst dates or
comedy stories for me that's why I do
comedy yeah exactly like nothing can
happen that I can't go on stage and work
through it and make people laugh agreed
with me at my expense I guess it's it's
a it's such a dream to have these crazy
things happen whether it's a funny
sexual experience or a getting ghosted
and be able to share it so hard recently
yeah
crazy oh it was it was gnarly okay but
this is so great because something so
wonderful came out of it because it
really like hurt my feelings because the
person and I had a great date and we
made a plan to meet up that weekend and
you know I it was just it just felt very
adult and you know it felt like oh this
is there's something here maybe yeah um
which I know from like one date that
sounds psycho no it doesn't it doesn't
it's just I've met people and been like
you were put on the earth for me in a
couple of hours it doesn't sound crazy
you know I'm not sure I was investing
that much but I definitely thought and
also we hate him because he goes to Jew
well I thought maybe we would meet up
for the plan we made that weekend
complete ghost and so I called my
therapist Barry which I know sounds
bougie and that's not it Barry is like
one of the hot most high road thinking
people I've ever met and I was speaking
to him and I was just saying God I just
missed that Jack Berger Post-It note we
all vilified him in Sex in the City for
the Post-it note I'm sorry I can't don't
hate me and this was the bad guy this
guy in this day and age would be a
freaking Saint
sorry all right you know something's not
Kosher here yeah I can't well guess what
now I get to move forward with my life
yeah I know know what you're thinking
and feeling which is it's not on it's
not happening it's not for me you're not
for me it's not for me I can't yes don't
hate me as look I acknowledge something
like a little weird is happening here
but look that's just how it's got to be
because I can't can I ask more questions
about this please so you had a plan
yeah also what's his name I thought you
were gonna say I called my publicist
you're like I call my therapist you're
like call Page Six we have a story
exactly I called Barry the greatest man
like thinker and I basically said you
know I there's a part of me that wants
to text him and say gosh I you know this
is so awkward if we do run into each
other you know I just don't like meeting
people and not having things be above
board so like clearly no plans but I and
then I'm like as I'm telling him this
I'm like this is so stupid I know this
is my ego talking
and this is not coming from the part of
me that I accept of myself so I don't
know what to do I just want the Jack
Berger Post-It note it would have made
it all okay what I like to do is just
send a ghost Emoji
I see you and you close to me
this is okay this is that's the next
thing I'm gonna do okay Drew you gotta
do it soon though because you can't it
can't be a Halloween text yeah I think
the statue of limitations is gone but
here's what Barry told me and I'm so
into it I was like why why couldn't I
just get the Jack Burger Post-It note
that's all I wanted he goes well you can
write the Jack Burger Post-It note to
yourself oh my gosh and I was like you
just took all the Heat and fire and
passion for me to make this make sense
to me through another human being and
I'm closing the book on it I feel whole
I'm moving on it's like literally in the
rear view mirror and I'm driving away
all that energy to want to control it
understand it fix it or say my piece is
gone because I now know he couldn't he's
maybe sorry and like I don't hate like
it just all of a sudden if you can say
for yourself someone can't it's like
it's so healing yeah I also think rain
and I did an episode on this recently
and we were inspired by this article in
New York mag maybe New York mag this guy
um poppy his quote I'm not going to get
it right but it was
why would you want to be with somebody
that's going to do that anyway it's like
really rude it's disrespectful it's
cowardly I guess there's also
extenuating circumstances of course
there could always be a situation where
there's a death and family they died but
like it's really not good behavior and
it's such a red flag when people do that
when they have a nice time and just
disappear so and makeup kind of out and
yeah so that's kind of our our closure
is like you don't want that person I
know it's not such a hot take but it's
like no it's the hottest take first of
all if you need the burger Post-It note
write it to yourself if that's not
enough for you the ghost Emoji might be
the most delicious takeaway and piece of
a prompt ever and at the ultimate
question is why would you want to engage
with this person at all who would treat
anyone that way absolutely man up and
like go off or lady app who it gets
girls goes to oh my God I love you you
just solved ghosting
I'm not kidding you have an a b or c
menu of options whereas a few weeks ago
I felt so helpless and stupid I mean if
everybody feels stupid and like I think
it really probably empowers people that
even like Drew Barrymore could get
ghosted like what hope do I was thinking
it makes us all feel really small and
when you really think about it this
person doesn't know you I mean you can
Wikipedia you but he doesn't know
anything about us everybody can
contribute to and say weird things right
he doesn't know you he doesn't know
anything about you and that's not like a
mark against the value that you bring to
the world it's like oh this person just
decided to like ghost out of this like
it doesn't mean you're any less
interesting smart beautiful sexy any of
those things that you're just a stranger
to them and they just got busy and
didn't respect you to say like hey I
don't see a romantic future yep exactly
and I just the reason I do love talking
about it and this kind of goes back to
the intro that we were talking about is
I love sharing it because it's you know
you said like who would do that to you
and it's so funny it's like oh no I'm
just a another girl out there who's
dealing with the same stuff that you
know we're all dealing with and through
technology and portals there is now new
behaviors that we are contending with in
the romance world and we are all in this
together and it is incredibly relative
we are all literally trying to navigate
the new normals and figure out how to
empower ourselves and I I just I think I
think we're all in this together and the
more you talk about it the more you
realize exactly what you said when your
fiance walked in is I'm the only one
that's going through this and it's like
the more you talk about it you'll feel
less alone absolutely yeah yeah all
right well Story number two our next
topic is from dawn dating described as
people who prefer going on early morning
dates to ground hogging which means that
you keep dating the same type over and
over again there's an endless amount of
dating terms to keep up with and I was
wondering what are some of the terms
that you've been using and do you have a
fave
um so I we just we always laugh at this
stuff because it's like they're just
constantly rebranding Behavior like it's
just like people are like I need a new
BuzzFeed like article let me Rebrand
this bizarre behavior I read this
article and like one of the things that
it was beige flags and it made me laugh
so hard we did it on the news and that's
what we find people right it just means
that they're boring so you want a dating
app and you're like oh this is a beige
flag
people people say I love like family and
friends and meeting new people like
that's a huge beige flag to me yeah I
love travel yeah yeah so does everyone
okay but this might actually get into a
richer conversation about sud beige
flags that are again seemingly like
negative or have some albatross around
their little necks and oh beige flag so
boring in between red and green flags
lies beige are we all supposed to be
looking at beige Flags through a
different lens because red and green
might be a little severe in One
Direction or another so I would like you
to say what you said to me the other day
because I was talking about this guy
might be a little boring and she was
like oh God no I can't wait so first of
all rain and I are not huge fans of
dating apps in the first place you know
and and a lot of I guess both men and
women but a lot of men phone it in it's
am I it's gonna be boring they did it on
the Fly they're not thinking that deeply
about it it may not matter that much to
them they may have something stupid like
I love my family it's like that's that's
nice that's not a bread yeah so it's I
try not to read too deeply into that for
me if I'm calling someone boring it's
because we did meet in person or you
know whatever but Rayna is kind of has
gone out with this guy we met him along
in the winter and they've reconnected
because I've forced her to reach out to
him and he he she just doesn't love his
texting and that it's not so like spicy
and exciting but she likes him in person
so who cares you know like I I brought
it up I was like yeah your ex was the
best texter alive so was mine it was
banter it was witty they were comedians
you know but that didn't work out for a
ton of reasons that they weren't our
match so if this guy's got everything
else you like and you enjoy him in
person we can let the texting go I know
it's not ideal we love to text rain and
I text all day long we love banter we
love witty people but that's not a
reason to write someone someone off can
we do this like every week yeah I guess
that you'll be the third co-host I'm not
kidding yeah where are the other two
co-hosts on your show I've been so
excited to do this with you guys and so
honored that you would like lend your
time over here on our field and if
there's anything like I don't want to
invite myself over but I would love to
come on early anytime you know these are
the kind of conversations that we're all
having thing offline so to be having
them online is so fun because they're
you know this is I just really
appreciated everything you just said and
it's such good girlfriend advice you
know I don't know what it is that men
are looking for I'm not a man
um but maybe it's the same thing and I
just don't know that and realize it but
as a girl and a woman like I just really
loved everything you said and I think
it's really solid advice thanks I mean
yeah these are the conversations we have
all day every day I don't know how and I
still have things to talk about four and
a half years later but
um yeah 2.5 million people a month say
but we laughed I laughed at the dawn
dating because we're in it used to I
never thought that it was weird that I
like to go on Day dates and she's been
roasting me for years it's crazy that I
go out in the daylight and I have the
skin to carry a day date okay I look
fine in the daylight but I don't want to
do it I want to meet you at sexy time I
know no I'm saying you do too I just I
Ashley is a whole skincare routine I
barely wash my face with water you look
great
um I don't I want to be in the dark sexy
time I want to be like sitting between
your legs I'd like there would be a
possibility of like leg touching I'm not
doing it at four o'clock she just she
makes fun of me so hard if I go out with
a guy before the sunsets
I got the best Day dates
dating too it's kind of like partying
during the day like and then being in
bed by six you know like that's my I
want to go out on a date I want to like
have some fun I want to like blow it out
and then at 6 p.m I'm home in bed with
my like doordash do you like that too on
a Saturday we'll go out to dinner with
girlfriends if I could be home by 10 oh
if someone makes this six o'clock res
I'm like say less yeah that's nice yeah
and 8pm res is red flag for me I know
um all right well we'll be right back
after this break to serve you more news
including the chore Kourtney Kardashian
is doing completely butt naked
all right everybody and we're back a
woman is seeking advice since a friend
um in her Circle consistently forgets to
venmo her back she won't even pay up for
a 20 karaoke night despite allegedly
hogging the mic all night how do you go
about fixing this it's really
uncomfortable when somebody forgets to
pay you back I'm people can read this
article her the way she went about crazy
yeah I mean I think that you just have
to say like you send a two bedroom
request and then you text the person I
need the money like I even if you have a
bunch of money you don't owe it to
somebody else to pay for anything and I
think it's perfectly fine to text them a
couple more times and then I would stop
inviting them to stuff yeah we were
saying like that is the nice thing about
the venmo request is you shoot the
request out there sometimes I miss them
you don't always see them then you can
follow up with the text like hey did you
and you just play dumb did you get my
venmo request this was interesting
because a what the girl is Rich or she
has money so the one that's not paying
um so they brought that up but then
basically this girl wasn't paying she
has this track record of not paying and
the other girl just replaced her in the
group outing without telling her so that
would have been such a good opportunity
to be like if you if you don't pay for
the thing
you don't have a ticket and I'm gonna
invite someone else and that could have
been a teachable moment of start paying
for stuff instead she just kind of like
bought iced her yeah which ghosted her
yeah she goes to her it's just such an
easy way also paying for things ahead of
time is such an easy way to be able to
say to a person yeah I need to replace
you with somebody who is going to pay me
for this so like not to ice them out but
like other people would like to come to
this they will give me money if you
would not like to give me money I will
go get it from another person that's
super Fair anything yeah this was kind
of this is an issue we want to validate
it your friends that don't pay you back
you have to ask multiple times it's
awkward you can decide if you want to be
their friend you should just definitely
stop paying for them if you want to
continue the friendship and don't cover
them anymore but this was kind of one of
those weird things that's actually best
case scenario for those type of people
because it was a pay in advance type of
thing right you know we were talking
well that's a solve everybody pays in
advance and whoever doesn't they don't
come yeah this is a ticketed event or
whatever it is or Raina just did a
birthday dinner recently and the the
girl who was hosting it sent out like
this is the the deal this is how much it
is so everybody knows what to expect
venomy in advance you know it's just
kind of it does suck to have a friend
like that but there are our ways around
it if you want to keep the friendship
yeah I just pay for everything okay
um so I don't know I'm like you know
what I don't care just I'll take care of
it
I got this
um
yeah I don't care about this advice
with me I'm not asking you for sure I'll
I've got it we're good I think we're
talking to like 23 year olds that like
totally on it totally it's true I'm 48
and I've worked since I was 11 months
old I've got your I've got your
character Sex in the City you pay for
the drink like what is it in your 20s
you're in your 30s and your 40s yeah I
think even in my 20s I did the same
thing but again I started working 11
months old by the time I was in my 20
people at seven I paid to rent at like
three years old so
screwed up with
Michael I've got this Drew you can come
out with us anytime we'll pay for you
and I tip really well I bet like I I
might have a tipping problem
is there such a thing
um okay our next story Kourtney
Kardashian claims that she did the
dishes completely butt naked to take
advantage of being away from her kids
while with Travis Barker in Palm Springs
thoughts did you watch this clip oh
there's a clip it's from the second
episode of the Kardashians oh what's the
clip um it's the clip is her telling her
mom about it um her mom and Corey come
over and they're like where are you guys
and then they have dinner together and
she's like sitting over tacos with her
mom being like and then I just did the
dishes naked I mean whatever go off and
do whatever you want I don't feel the
need to tell my mom I like God and then
like walked around and did chores like I
don't my mom knows I don't need to tell
her I'm here with my husband like her
need to constantly Ram down everybody's
throat like I'm getting
it's it's different it's not for me but
like go off I mean I guess she was a
Scott for so many years and they had
separate bedrooms and she wasn't like
doing is that true because they have
separate bedrooms so I don't know her
personally but they talked about it a
lot oh really keeps up more yeah yeah um
yeah they had like separate bedrooms I
remember when she got pregnant with the
third kid I think Kim said to her like
he's not like a sperm donor but don't
you think that like I don't know the
producer was like Hey this will make a
good headline tell your mom You did
dishes naked and then like you can see
the headline and it's this like sexy tip
I mean it's just everything feels I
agree with my the mom like that's I just
did I I can't in front of Corey yeah
my mom and I are like I would be like
yeah I don't know I actually can't I
haven't lived with a man in quite some
time I forget what it's like but I don't
I I just feel like crystals
but I will say to Kourtney Kardashian
directly and you know no mother or
boyfriend of mother
um that um I totally when I'm alone and
my kids are at their dad's I totally
strut around naked and I lock all the
doors and I literally like I love it so
much there's a sense of me that thinks
this is crazy you know it's not that I'm
even like so free and comfortable but I
still enjoy it I'm like I'm in a state
of being slightly torn but I'm so
excited to have the opportunity so I I I
I totally get it totally this is this
that's why I'm like why is this news
right right right so would you do the
dishes naked too yeah I think the dishes
are a good thing to do you don't want to
cook naked you get like a splatter a
grease on your body yeah
yeah I know that's not a sudden pasta
night is at the ER but
um yeah yeah I think the right again
this is something that we we did we've
done episodes on how to keep the romance
alive do spicy stuff around the house
like why not I'm just I'm just trying to
think if I'd want my partner to be I
just want to be doing the dishes a guide
with the dishes what if he bends over
though like he's naked he bend over you
see a bundle I don't want it oh true
he's like Philadelphia anatomy and
female anatomy are so different
sexy I think this is funny because so
many couples fight about the dishwasher
yeah and it's like you're fighting now
you're like I'm naked and he's telling
me how to load it properly and this went
terribly wrong but my mom and dad would
my mom would be butt naked in my dad
would like Cindy you gotta put the
knives down you know
maybe this could also be like a like
rock scissors paper for whoever has to
do the dishes and the other one gets to
be naked and you turn it into a whole
section yeah I think it's sexy to do
chores naked um I don't know that I
would tell my mom about it but Chris
seemed turned on by it to be honest your
stepdad chip
if you told Chip right has this like
funny stepdad he's always wearing a
statement shirt he's always looking like
he's about to actually was strutting
around my house in the tiniest little
shorts I made like good for Chip he gets
to see some ass finally I forgot he was
in the house and I came downstairs and
reina's Mom's house and I was wearing
little booty shorts and I have never
forgotten it it was traumatizing for
everybody were you doing the dishes I
made a sandwich so even sexier
by the way that probably is every man's
fantasy booty shorts and food great
um okay our final story let's end on a
fun note there are reportedly eight
green flags
um in a relationship that you definitely
should pay attention to since we've had
a you know consistent flag conversation
um one of the green flags is feeling
like a team I like that I wave that
green flag
um the other is uh if they say they're
gonna do something do it they do it I
like that green flag too what are some
of your green flags when it comes to
dating so that one that I'm saying what
they're gonna do is when I read the
article I was hoping that was on there
because that's probably the one that we
discussed the most it's so important
showing up when you say you're gonna
show up someone you can rely on
consistency all those things
um we've even discussed different
attachment Styles and insecure
attachment with an avoidant attachment
and like if the least you can do is just
be consistent and show up attachment is
another word that Barry and I have
discussed
um and it is so powerful like I had a
real attachment issue ironically to my
job here
um like for the first two years I was
really scared that it was just going to
go away at any moment
um and we launched in a pandemic and I
was incredibly attached to this like I
it's just it makes me so fulfilled and
it makes me so happy and
um he would talk to me a lot about
attachment and it was so it doesn't
always just have to be in relationships
with other humans like with your parents
or your lover or you know your friends
it can be a lot of different things uh
the word and the feeling and the idea of
attachment but it's a very powerful
thing to bring up because once you
realize that you have an attachment to
something you can immediately start to
sort of unweave yourself from the web so
that's A Great Notion of discussing
attachment in many different forms
I love that I like discussing
attachments to things other than
romantic Partners yeah I mean nothing in
the world means more to me than girls
got to eat in this community and I just
I'm so honored that we get to do this I
get to do it with like my best friend
and it's so fun we've affected all these
people and I say like I don't even care
if I have children because like I have
like we've raised all these daughters
it's really like special and beautiful
and um of course I want a romantic
relationship of course I want to partner
like everybody else but like I have this
other thing and I have all these
friendships and I'm very attached to
like what we've built
um Randy you've got to have a favorite
from that article because it did say
boundaries
I do I do love boundaries and somebody
who's respecting them you know you know
what I liked in that article was um I I
for a huge green flag to me is looking
zooming out and looking at the person's
life and saying do they have good
relationships with friends and family
yeah and I think you can sort of Base
what your relationship might be like
romantic relationships are different but
I want to know that like you have solid
healthy relationships with other people
and that you have a life outside of me
that you're going to bring things into
my life I love when somebody has a bunch
of friends and I get to meet new people
and they have like a cool family and
that's so fun for me and I just want to
look at what the relationships in your
life are like because if I constantly
hear you saying I want to date with this
guy he told me he hated his brother and
him and his sister had a bad
relationship and of course there's a lot
of layers to that why that might be the
case but I was just like okay let me
note this this person has two siblings
he has issues with both of them like
what's going on here I could not agree
more
um Reyna I went out on a date with a guy
and the whole time all he did was talk
trash about everyone including family
members
in-laws uh friends and people in his
industry anytime I brought someone up
trying to just desperately make
conversation with this negative Nelly I
swear to gosh all I kept thinking is oh
God you are so toxic like this is so bad
yes and it will suck you in there are
people who have this bond that like all
they do is just talk together complaint
Bond and those those people are like bad
for your psyche I just cannot tell you
enough how much I have enjoyed this I
really want to do this again I feel like
I'm developing a little bit of
attachment right now sure I feel like we
should take you out to dinner and pay
for you
[Laughter]
I won't fight you on it you you
bargained since you were 11 months old
that's true I've got everyone covered I
really do I mean Ashley and Reina it's
so obvious why you have this big
community and following and I'm so
grateful that the world has you guys in
it I feel lucky to be in your sphere and
I just want more thank you so much oh my
gosh thank you so much thank you
seriously all right follow the Drew's
News podcast wherever you get your
podcast and if you like the podcast then
you know you can tell a friend or you
know you can um you know meet somebody
somewhere and say like hey my name is
have you heard the Drew's news podcast
or you know if you get into some type of
odd fender bender as you're giving your
insurance information you can say you
know I've been listening to this podcast
lately I was just thinking it made me
laugh maybe we need to laugh after this
hideous situation
um you know it just if it comes to the
top of Mind yay um and be sure to watch
the Drew Barrymore show every weekday by
going to the Drew Barrymore show.com and
then you can find your local time and
channel and as always Raina and Ashley
I'll sign off by saying to everyone we
make this show for you so take it with
you but I'm certainly going to be taking
this conversation with me thank you